we're told we know that five times three
is equal to 15 yep that's true
so which of the following statements are
also true and it says to choose two
answers so pause this video and see if
you can work through that all right now
let's go through them one by one so this
first one says three is a multiple of 15
now in order for three to be a multiple
of 15 that means that we can multiply 15
by some whole number to get to three but
a multiple of 15 we're thinking 15 30 45
it's not going to be three what whole
number can I multiply 15 by to get three
if I multiply 15 by one I'm already at
15 so this is not going to be our choice
and since they say pick two answers well
we might be able to figure out these but
let's just read them into to make sure
that they make sense 15 is a multiple of
three
so that means I can multiply 3 times
some whole number to get to 15 and we
know what that whole number is it's 5
they tell us right over there 5 times 3
is 15 so 15 is a multiple of 3 15 would
also be a multiple of 5 because I can
multiply 5 by the whole number 3 to get
to 15 so I like this choice 5 is a
factor of 15 well a factor factors of a
number of numbers that you can multiply
together to get that number so 5 is a
factor of 15 and 3 is a factor of 15
because 5 times 3 is 15 so this one is
also true it would have also been true
if they said 3 is a factor of 15 or if
they said 15 is a multiple of 5 any of
those would have been true statements
based on what we know that 5 times 3 is
equal to 15